[Music]  alright so there I am I'm sitting on  this couch and Diane Sawyer is coming on  my young kids especially Kendall and  Kylie they don't want anybody to hurt  their daddy now I am sitting on the  couch with all my girls Courtney here  really Chloe Kendall Kylie this is by  far the most social media family in the  world they can sit there with their  little phones and reach 140 million  people okay just like all over the world  just like all of a sudden all these  positive comments started coming in Lady  Gaga just said something you know how  great this is Miley Cyrus gets on and  she goes crazy Elton John comes on it  starts talking about how great this is  you name it they were all just going  crazy on social media I think at that  point it made my two little girls who  obviously live in that world I think it  made it feel really good that you know  what it's going to be okay people still  love my daddy  [Music]  you